supply chains and modernizing port
operations and today i wanted to
highlight that the department of
transportation
awarded 12.6 million dollars in grants
to nine marine highway projects across
the country in delaware hawaii indiana
kentucky louisiana north carolina new
york new jersey tennessee texas and
virginia these investments through amer
the america's marine highway program
will help us move more goods more
quickly and more efficiently and help
our agricultural exports get goods to
market the announcement follows the
successful first stop step of the port
action plan which provided the port of
savannah 8 million dollars to set up
container yards in georgia and north
carolina freeing up dock space and
speeding up the flow of goods in and out
of the port three container sites are
already in operation in savannah
statesboro and atlanta and are already
supporting georgia businesses such as
home depot carter and agricultural
exporters and one more piece of good
news for shipping costs new data today
uh confirms the cost of shipping a
container between asia and the west
coast is more than 25 lower than it was
three months ago so about four or sorry
six thousand dollars i was not a math
major six thousand dollars lower than it
was three months ago as this chart shows
you and that's important for the
american people to understand and know
because if the cost of shipping a
container is less expensive it means
that more goods can be shipped shipped
that there should be more on the st the
shelves
stocked and that the cost of goods also
will come down we've seen that uh play
out but this is definitely a positive
sign i also wanted to give you a bit of
a sense of the week ahead we'll have
more to come in the coming uh days i
promise but i can confirm for you that
on thursday the president will award the
medal of honor to three army soldiers
for acts of gallantry and intrepidity
above and beyond the call of duty and
their stories are so amazing i just
wanted to take a brief moment to
highlight a couple of them uh sergeant
first class uh alwyn cash will receive
the medal of honor posthumously for his
service as a platoon sergeant in iraq on
october 17 2000 2005. cash was
conducting a nighttime mounted patrol
when the bradley fighting vehicle he was
in charge of was attacked by enemy small
arms fire an improvised explosive device
disabled the vehicle causing it to
become engulfed in flames after
extracting himself he set about
extracting the driver and his peers
trapped in the troop compartment despite
the severe second and third degree burns
covering the majority of his body he
repeatedly entered the burning building
to retrieve his fellow soldiers he
selflessly
refused evacuation until all of the
other wounded soldiers were evacuated
uh his heroic actions at the cost of his
life saved the lives of his teammates
also
being awarded a medal of honor is
sergeant first class uh christopher
solis who will receive the matter of
honor also posthumously for service as
the leader of special of the special
operations unit in afghanistan on july
12 2018. sergeant sales led an operation
to clear an area of enemy forces when a
large enemy force attacked sergeant
sergeant first class soliz voluntarily
exposed himself to intense enemy fire
multiple times to retrieve and employ a
heavy weapon system direct and lead a
medical evacuation via helicopter and
act as a physical shield for his team
the aircraft and its crew after being
hit by enemy fire he motioned to the
aircraft to depart rather than remain to
load himself load him his selfless
actions saved the life of the evacuated
uh partner uh partnered force member and
almost certainly prevented further
casualties he died of the wounds he
received in combat and finally major
sergeant earl plumly will receive the
medal of honor for his service as a
weapons sergeant in afghanistan on
august 28 2013. then staff sergeant
plumley uh plumlee responded to a
complex enemy attack when a massive
explosion tore 60-foot reach in the
base's perimeter wall and 10 insurgents
wearing suicide vests poured through
staff sergeant pumley and five special
operations members mounted two vehicles
and raced toward the site of the
detonation without cover and with
complete disregard for his own safety
staff sergeant plumley repeatedly
advanced on the enemy force engaging
multiple insurgents with only his pistol
killing two insurgents and engaging
combatants at close range including an
insurgent whose suicide vest exploded a
mere seven meters from his position
undeterred he joined a small group of
american and polish soldiers who moved
to counter-attack the infiltrators and
carried a wounded soldier to safety so
the president looks forward to honoring
two of those individuals posthumously
and one
on next thursday when he awards the
medal of honor with that colleen why
don't you kick us off okay thanks jen um
i wanted to ask two questions one is um
can you talk a little bit about the
you know white house outreach to senator
manchin and other senators um on the
build back better act in relation to the
recent cpi index reports today and then
the second question is um
i wonder what else the white house can
do or should be doing um with regards to
women's reproductive rights given
everything that's happening um
specifically today there was a ruling
out of texas that keeps the restrictions
intact while the court um sorry while
the um lawsuits play out so i just
wondered what else aside from the
classification of roe in congress and i
mentioned the administration absolutely
well let me take the first one first uh
let me first say that um as it relates
to the cpi or the consumer price index
data this morning let me start with the
data the data was taken in november
even since that time over the course of
the last nearly two weeks we've seen a
decrease in costs in some of the areas
that account for a big percentage of the
rise in inflation so about fifty percent
of this uh of this infl these
inflation's number of the inflation
numbers excuse me is attributed to the
rising gas prices and the rise in car
prices on gas prices and we had a chart
maybe they'll pull it up again uh that
brian deese our any siege director
talked about just yesterday what we've
seen in recent days are gas prices are
coming down from their peak and this
obviously isn't
is not captured in the data since the
data was through the course of november
so in 20 states gas is below their
20-year average in real terms and
natural gas is down 25 percent from its
november average we attribute this to a
range of factors including the president
tapping the strategic petroleum reserve
in coordination with partners around
around the world
but more broadly we're seeing positive
signs of supply chain bottlenecks being
addressed that are helping address this
as well and we expect those numbers to
continue to decrease across the country
the other piece
that and gas size i should also note
sorry on the wholesale market is down
over 30 cents per gallon since its peak
uh which is again a good sign um
the other piece as we're seeing as it
relates to cars is wholesale car uh
prices are are down as well a used car
prices are down as well so when car
dealers are purchasing cars uh they are
at a lower cost than they were before
for a range of reasons including the
availability of chips because we've
helped solve uh some issues in the
supply chain that means that as we look
to the first quarter of next year or the
first couple of months of next year
those car prices are going to keep
coming down one other third note let me
just note in the data
one of of course the
factors as it relates to costs that
consumers are experiencing the american
people are experiencing is of course the
cost of food when you go to the grocery
store 25 of that our economists or
economic experts estimate is uh related
to meat prices you go you buy a pound of
burger you buy a poultry whatever it may
be and our assessment here and we've
taken steps as it relates to our
competition agenda is that dominant
corporations in these industries are
taking advantage of their market power
to raise prices while increasing their
own profit margins meat prices are a
very good example of that something
we're working to crack down on and just
to give you a sense gross profit margins
for big meat processes for up 50 and net
margins are up over 300 percent that
should not be the case that is not all
attributed to supply chain issues etc so
i just wanted to dig into some of the
data things there first but i will note
as it relates to how this how we have
these conversations now with this data
out our our argument is that this makes
passing bill back better even more
imperative even more important because
what bill back better will do is it will
start cutting costs early next year
including for child care costs cutting
them in half in 2022 making preschool
free for many families starting in 2022.
saving families the uh saving families
the 8 600 a typical family currently
spends on preschool uh leading to the
construction of additional housing units
starting in 2022. these are all areas
the way people and the president just
talked about this too experience
inflation as you all know is not through
the data or graphs as much as we love
graphs in here but it's about the costs
on their family budgets and so that's
why in our in our view and the
president's view the argument is even
stronger to get it done now the last
thing i would note on this and then i'll
get to the other question you had is
that the president just noted and i
don't know if you saw that he would be
speaking with senator manchin early next
week obviously we're in touch at a staff
level but i will leave it of course to
senator manchin to speak to that further
as it relates to the question about the
supreme court
ruling this morning one uh you can the
president has obviously been at uh
former senator dole's funeral for the
majority of the day uh but we will be
issuing a statement in his name we
naturally wanted him to see and review
and edit first so you will all be
getting that shortly uh but let me just
note that we are the president is very
concerned uh by the supreme court's
decision allowing sba to remain in
effect given the consequences the law
has for women in texas and around the
country and for the rule of law uh i
know you noted this but i would just
like to reiterate that the president is
deeply committed to the constitutional
right recognizing roe v wade uh and he
uh has
uh has argued and advocated in the past
for codifying roe through passing the
women's health protection act and the
ruling this morning is a reminder of how
how much these rights are at risk
and how women across the country who
have now
in texas especially it's been 101 days
since this was put in place 101 days
where their health their their health
their access to what has been law of the
land for many decades now has been
questioned and put and
challenged and so this is just a
reiteration of how much a reinforcement
i should say of how important it is to
codify row and move forward with the
women's health protection act and
certainly hopeful that they will move
forward with that it's already passed
the house so in the senate i would know
in terms of additional administration
actions
hhs announced a department-wide response
to protect patients and providers in
response to texas law sba these actions
include and they will continue to be
built upon in coordination with the
gender policy council here
issuing title 10 grant support for
health service providers with title 10
grantees receiving significant funding
to support expansion of family planning
services as well as plan to expand
access to emergency contraception and
family planning services to any eligible
applicant these are steps that have
already been underway but we will
continue to explore what more can be
done all right go ahead jeff hi jen what
are the next steps in the u.s process to
extradite to julian assange after the
latest uk court decision
well this is really a case uh for it's
an ongoing criminal case uh so i'd refer
you to the department of justice and
their statement uh the president is
committed to an independent department
of justice and so we'd really let them
speak to any next steps and on another
topic russia spelled out some specific
demands for nato today including that
nato should rescind its promises that
ukraine and georgia may eventually join
the alliance and that nato not deploy
weapons in countries that border russia
what's the us response to that have you
seen those and can you give us an update
on
when that meeting between the other nato
countries the u.s and russia will take
place well this list which we have
certainly seen but should not come as a
surprise it's the same list of demands
that uh the russians have been
advocating for and voicing for several
months if not years uh and and that is
their prerogative uh to have to have
their views and demands we have our own
and we have our own uh concerns about
security circumstances around the world
including of course on the border of
russia and ukraine russia can raise
their concerns we can raise ours
europeans can raise their concerns
that's the whole point of having a
dialogue and a discussion
well i don't have an update on what
format that may take which i think is
the second part of your question it's
important to note that there have been
formats for conversations about european
security with russia for 70 years
approximately
and many of those are formats that could
work and we are open to
being the format moving forward i would
note also that even even as we're
determining what that looks like
we have been engaged on a daily basis
with all of the players here our
european partners at a range of levels
obviously you saw the president have the
call with the
b9 leaders yesterday as well as the
ukrainians but we are in touch with
through senior officials at the state
department in the white house and we
will continue to be but i don't have any
update at this point on the format right
thanks john um the president said just a
few moments ago that he thought that
inflation may be at its peak right now
is that the determination of your
economic team when they look when they
analyze kind of the state of play in the
market right now or where is he kind of
facing what's he basing
well i think if the president we're
standing here i know he's always invited
which may be the next thing someone says
uh but which is okay you're invited if
you're listening um uh is that would be
that we of course uh defer to the
federal reserve uh and their assessments
and that they make as they make
predictions about inflation they are
predicting as outside economists are
that inflation will come down next year
um so we would really defer to them as
would the president uh i think i have
not obviously had a chance to speak to
him post his comments because it was
just shortly uh uh
not so long ago uh but i think what he
is in his mind as he went on to
articulate is what we're doing to lower
costs for the american people and that's
how he sees it is of course inflation is
here we use at the federal reserve a
very important economic term the way the
american people experience this at home
is costs and and what things cost
whether it is uh the cost of gas or
natural gas heating your home or putting
gas in your car we're seeing those
prices come down or whether it is buying
a car again we're projecting those
prices will come down we're obviously
working to bring the cost of food down
so we are seeing those move in a good
trajectory and in a good direction and i
think that's how he was articulating it
and then you guys have been consistent
on your argument as it relates to build
that better and inflation now for weeks
if not months
senator manchin has been consistent in
his position for weeks and not months
obviously something is going to need to
change in that dynamic on the senator's
side of things for him i presume to
support bill back better
what changes in your argument that
resonates with the senator given his
long-held positions here on inflation
well
we will certainly let the senator speak
for himself he will of course be
speaking with the president as the
president alluded to
early next week and i would expect the
president will convey
much of which we've what we've conveyed
publicly that uh while we've seen costs
increase in some areas and we've seen
a good direct that move in a good
direction in some areas as well uh what
we need to do now is think about what
we're going to do about rising costs
what is our plan to address rising costs
uh you know you saw every single
republican uh in the house vote against
built back better what were they voting
against yes they were voting against the
president's agenda they were also voting
against lowering costs they were voting
against lowering costs for child care
lowering costs for elder care lowering
costs for health care
and i think the not argument because he
has a very good working relationship
with senator manchin but i think the
case he will make is that
this is exactly the time to pass this
bill and move it forward so that we can
lower costs for the american people on
all of those topics including insulin
and areas that really uh pinch force
american families to pinch pennies
on that same point though just
politically do these numbers make it
more challenging you think to pass those
back better given the fact that
opponents and even manchin argue that
pouring more money into the economy will
only make things worse
well what we know is what 17 nobel
economists laureate economists have
conveyed which is that this will help
address inflation we know that
economists across the board many many
across the board have conveyed that this
will help address what we see as rising
costs and we also know that for american
families sitting at home they don't
necessarily think of it as what the data
and what the economists are saying they
think of it as what their daily what
their weekly budgets are what their
monthly budgets are and who which leader
has a plan to address that so actually
for us politically arguing we're going
to bring down the cost of child care
we're going to bring down the cost of
preschool we're going to make affordable
housing a reality and on the other side
of the aisle you have people who are
opposed to lowering that cost is a
pretty viable argument and on the
timeline here just to put a finer point
on it you've noted some the costs are
already going down that may not be
reflected
in this report
and that you may see changes next year
but you know you're an american at home
worried about these rising prices uh how
long do you think americans should be
prepared for these increased prices to
persist well i think the way amer the
american people look at it is not
through data right they look at it
through how things are impacting their
lives so what they can know is that gas
prices are coming down in about 20
states across the country we expect that
to happen and
natural gas prices are coming down that
means if they're looking to heat their
homes it was a very cold day here
yesterday for other cold days around the
country those prices are coming down if
they're looking to buy a used car those
prices should come down early next year
and also their steps we're taking to
address uh areas of uh where where we
see prices increasing like when they go
to the store to buy some you know
burgers for a barbecue um that we're
working to go after meat conglomerates
for raising prices and jacking prices up
so
it's in it's it's area to area but what
we can tell them is where we're seeing
progress where we're still going after
the problem and what we would also
convey to them is you should look
closely at who has a plan here and who's
just shouting from a megaphone about it
being a problem we all agree it's a
problem it's who's going to do something
about it and how worried are you that
the fed may have to
raise interest rates
we really of course defer to the
independence of the federal reserve and
making uh those decisions and what they
feel is right for the economy so i
wouldn't say we're worried we leave them
to their independent assessment of
what's needed go ahead jen is the
mentioned conversation happening here at
the white house in person or by phone i
don't have anything on the format um and
obviously we've been in close touch with
senator manchin but i just was echoing
what the president said just a few
minutes ago and then on assange the high
court issued its ruling in part because
of assurances
from the administration that assange
would not be kept under the harsh
conditions that are typically reserved
for high security prisoners can you talk
about what assurances those were and
where he might be held well we should
it's really all through the department
of justice which is where those
discussions would happen so i'd really
point you to them
and then one more on cove because the
president received a briefing yesterday
is there anything you can share about
what the doctors told him especially
because it's been about two weeks since
dr fauci said it would be two weeks
until we had more definitive information
about omicron
uh well he said it would be two weeks a
few weeks obviously we want to wait
until there's an uh an assessment that
the doctors feel comfortable and
confident in providing to the american
people i don't have an update for you
here today uh but as soon as they have
an assessment to make uh they will make
it there's also a briefing this
afternoon with the kova team as well
yeah go ahead thanks jen um republicans
are circulating a modified version of
the cbo score for buildback better in
their version it included extensions of
programs
without being paid for which we
understand is not how the president put
forward this legislation but the reason
that they're saying they did that is
because uh lindsey graham says if you
believe these programs are going to go
away after one or two years
you shouldn't have a driver's license we
all know child tax credits are not going
to go away after a year
what does white house say to that well
uh to quote of all people norm ornstein
at the american enterprise institute who
put this quite well quote you can't
assume programs will be extended just
because lindsey graham wants to assure
that an estimate based on what's not in
the bill is bogus and fundamentally
dishonest i mean this is not a cbo score
this is a fake cbo score it's not about
the existing bill anybody is debating or
voting on uh this is about proposing the
extension of of programs that has not
been agreed to without the commitment of
the president which he's made repeatedly
publicly that he would never support
extending these programs if they weren't
paid for period that has been his
commitment that is his commitment i
would also note that there's a
particular irony here uh that i don't it
shouldn't be lost on senator graham
maybe it is lost on senator graham i
don't know uh that the plan they
proposed and passed for and passed into
law the 2017 tax cuts were two trillion
dollars which were not paid for in any
way shape or form that didn't seem to
upset them at all and i will say and
they can thank us in any way they would
like for this that what our projections
and the projections of our economists
predict is that for our plan um
uh in if as this plan continues in the
second decade
it would actually reduce the deficit by
two trillion dollars so we're actually
covering their irresponsible tax cuts to
corporations and highway and net wealth
individuals they're very welcome for
that thank you and then on crime the
national sheriff's association alleged
that they haven't seen the kinds of
federal support uh to crack down on
crime that we talked about here in the
briefing room earlier this week i
already have lengthy statements from the
white house and the doj
detailing and countering some of the
points that they made
but more broadly if the feeling among
communities and law enforcement groups
is that
things are getting worse and not better
and that they're not visibly enough
seeing
results from what the white house is
doing how can the white house project a
stronger image that they're tough on
crime and crack down on this
well jackie i would first say that we
recognize and let me just reiterate that
we agree that violent crime is a serious
problem
we have concerns about what we've seen
serious concerns about retail theft in a
range of communities across the country
and i know you are aware of this but we
have actually taken some what we would
consider serious steps to help work with
these communities whether it's plussing
up police forces in san francisco and
l.a or having the fbi work directly with
the la police department to address
areas where we have seen an increase in
retail theft i would also note that what
the president has proposed and obviously
we're on the cr short term budget right
now is an increase in a plus up in pr
and funding for the cops program of
almost 300 billion dollars more than
what was proposed by hit the former
president because he believes that
police of police departments and law
enforcement should be properly funded
and supported that is something he's
been a believer in his entire career so
i would say we are committed to but we
working we we have proposed additional
funding we are working directly now uh
and obviously this work is ongoing
one real quick one on the jesse smallett
verdict um both the president and vice
president tweeted um at the time of that
attack um
the president tweeted what happened to
jesse small that must never be tolerated
in this country we're with you jesse the
vice president called it an attempted
modern day lynching um since the guilty
verdict are there any lessons learned
here uh on rushing to judgment when a
crime is alleged i think uh there are
there are lessons learned perhaps for
everybody who commented uh at the time
including former president trump i wish
april ryan was here because i think she
asked him the question
do i see her somewhere or no okay she
just left where he said i can tell you
that it's horrible it's it's
doesn't get worse uh in response to her
question about the tri about the uh
about jesus millet at the time uh i
would say that we respect the jury's
decision lying to the police
particularly about something as heinous
as a hate crime is shameful an instances
of that need to be investigated fully
and those found guilty need to be
punished and false accusations divert
valuable police resources away from
important investigations they make it
harder for real victims to come forward
and be believed you know if you look
back at the time it's also true and
important to note that accusations of
hate crimes should be taken seriously
and they need to be fully investigated
but that's where everybody was looking
at it at the time but certainly knowing
what we know now it's important to also
note uh the danger of lying to police
and lying about hate crimes and the fact
that diverts important resources go
ahead kristen thank you jen i know
you've gotten some questions about the
timeline of inflation but let me just
try again in this context um i think it
bears repeating because now we have the
numbers
fed chair jerome powell said that
transitory is no longer the right way to
describe inflation he said it now
appears that factors pushing inflation
upward will linger well into next year i
asked brian dees this question yesterday
so let me put it to you today
given that given what jerome powell is
now saying does the administration does
the president acknowledge that inflation
is more entrenched and not transitory
well kristen i would say that i can't
speak obviously for jerome powell but i
think part of the point here is that
doesn't really matter what you call it
our view but more importantly the view
of the federal reserve which he oversees
private sector forecasters in the
markets has been and remains and has
been for months
that inflation will ease over time that
is the projections of the federal
reserve uh that is the projections of
outside forecasters
and that it will uh it will ease next
year
and that our supply chain issues and
higher prices are rooted in the pandemic
which will survi subside as it gets
under control so i can't parse for him
his comments but they make projections
on a regular basis uh on a predictable
basis uh which is important for the
market it's important for people to look
to as do we which i think is the most
important thing to watch they are
predicting as they have four months
which hasn't changed even when he made
those comments that it will subside uh
next year
i think when people hear the term well
into next year though i interviewed a
business owner today
some families who say it's this piling
up of crisis that's causing the
suffering what do you say to those
families
who are suffering and they hear
a term like well into next year and they
feel panicked i would say that we take
the rise in prices and that impacts
individual families small businesses
anyone across this country incredibly
seriously kristin and that's why it's so
important to note into detail as i did
at the beginning but i can highlight a
little bit more uh what the president is
doing and what this administration is
doing to lower prices and that includes
using every lever at our disposal to
lower gas prices something that's
impacting people across this country
we've seen some progress 20 states
across the country we've seen it go down
we expect that to increase another key
key driver in these inflation numbers is
the price of cars we're seeing wholesale
car prices come down that means when
families go to a lot to buy a used car
first quarter of next year the prices
will be lower and we're also using tools
uh at the president's disposal to go
after meat conglomerates where we're
seeing when people go to the grocery
store and a pound of meat is more
expensive than it should be we agree
that's less related to supply chain
issues a lot of that's related to uh the
uh the actions these conglomerates are
taking uh to take advantage of the
american people in the industry so what
people should understand is that the
president is focused on bringing down
costs and all of these industries how
they're impacting their daily lives
which is what's most important to him
and that also getting the build back
better agenda and bill passed will help
lower a range of costs that impact
people's bottom lines their pocketbooks
their budgets obviously the child tax
credit is a part of the buildback better
plan um i asked you about this yesterday
if there's any discussion about pulling
it out as a stand-alone piece
for the families who rely on that tax
credit will the president say to
congress don't leave until we get this
done to make sure that that child tax
credit does get extended what's his plan
for that i think it's important to note
that there's not a single republican who
supports extending the child tax credit
as i unless they want to speak out and
if they do they're welcome to join us in
supporting the extension of that uh we
believe that the the full package uh the
entirety of the package has key
components that will lower costs for
american families that's what we're
advocating to push to pass that's what
leader schumer would like to do and see
past and that's what her focus is on at
this point in time go ahead thanks um
going back to abortion um
what path does this might have see for
the women's health protection act given
the current balance in the senate
would you advocate for a filibuster card
out in order to pass that bill and
protect access abortion
uh i would say that we would like to see
that bill come up for a vote in the
senate uh we would like to see that bill
move forward but in terms of the
mechanism for that i don't have anything
new on that we will defer to leaders in
the senate also there's some reports
today about conversations among senators
about potentially exploring a rules
change to expedite ambassador
nominations
is the white house involved in this
conversation at all and how worried are
you about a scenario where your tensions
are escalating the border of ukraine and
you don't have ambassadors in some of
these key european cities we're deeply
worried about it you know it is true uh
let me first state having worked at the
state department for quite for a few
years that we have a very talented
foreign service uh
a foreign service team and officials
around the country around the world and
career officials that are around the
world uh but it should be that if
they're qualified talented experienced
nominees
who have been nominated by a president
to serve in key positions around the
world they should move forward through
the senate and what we're seeing now is
that there is still delay in process a
number of these nominees will end up
with a majority of votes not everyone
not everyone but a vast majority of
votes democrats and republicans yet
there's an insistence on hours and hours
of debate that's slowing the process and
you're absolutely right there are key
countries in the world where we have not
had ambassadors the president has been
in office for almost a year now and
they're still not confirmed so it is an
area of serious concern in terms of the
process piece i'd have to check on that
and our engagement i'll talk the
legislative team about that question
the
did an interview this week in which he
indicated that the uh 2500 troops in
iraq might come under increased pressure
from iranian-backed militias that want
the u.s out of iraq
one of the reasons the president pulled
out of afghanistan was because he was
afraid that american troops there would
come under increased risk the taliban
took over the country can you explain
why the u.s presence in iraq will remain
that the president was so interested for
that reason getting out of afghanistan
i i have to talk to our national
security team about their specific view
on this and probably the department of
defense and their team about it
i would say that afghanistan was of
course a war that we fought for 20 years
where we had troops on the ground uh and
who were fighting a war on behalf of the
afghans they were unwilling to fight for
themselves i know it's tempting to
compare different war zones they're
always a little different and have
different circumstances but i can check
with them on this specific case one
other question we understand the mother
of austin tice the journalist who's been
captive in syria for so long that was
going to be meeting with the national
security advisor you have an update on
on that meeting and does the us
government
have hope that austin tyson might soon
be returned to his family
well i can confirm that deborah tys met
with jake sullivan our national security
adviser today i would also note that
she has been and her family have been in
touch and have met a number of times
with members of our national security
team and been on phone calls as we have
been with all families of of individuals
who are held overseas uh it's our
standard practice not to share specific
details about any potential meetings or
specific cases out of respect for the
families and to preserve confidentiality
uh our team of course will remain in
close contact uh but i can't give you an
assessment obviously we're going to do
everything we can uh to bring austin
tice and any individual and any american
who's being held overseas go ahead
thanks jen um
first i just want to ask quickly uh the
chinese firm evergreen slipped into
default
uh you were asked about this a couple
months ago and said that the the us was
monitoring um but now that it's actually
happened i'm wondering uh
sort of what the level of concern is the
administration of the white house is
undertaking any
uh well uh the the vast majority of
their uh business and of course market
impact is in china not in the united
states as i think you well know
obviously any potential impact would be
monitored by the department of treasury
uh i have not heard any additional or
new assessment on that but of course we
certainly they monitor not only domestic
but also global markets
i just wanted to sort of diagram a
sentence that you you said earlier
it's a friday give me a break uh
well i'll explain okay you you were
talking about your chalkboard yeah the
the cbo uh
the cbo
um report sure non-existent bill and and
you and explaining why you didn't think
it was valid said that the president
would never
support extending these programs if they
weren't paid for period and the reason
i'm asking this question is i envision a
scenario where in like two or three
years i'm still sitting here maybe
you're not but uh but
wow
this is like a real harsh line of
questioning
you might be done with us but a blind
press secretary sitting here and you're
trying to extend
some element of buildback better because
as we all know
the package is not going to move
or the elements package wouldn't all
move together in a we're just renewing
buildback better so i want to be
extremely specific
if there's an element of buildback
better that expires the president will
never support renewing that element
unless it is fully paid for in deficit
neutral he wants to so he would only
support extending these programs if they
were paid for period i'm not going to
parse all individual moments but that is
what he has stated publicly that is his
commitment he is person who is fiscally
responsible unlike the person who asked
for the fake cbo score uh and that is
his commitment as long as he is
president if it's child tax credit or uh
you know payments for child care comes
up you know it's expiring it's on its
own you don't have a way i'm not going
to get ahead of a hypothetical but again
what this fake cbo score was about was
extending all the programs that would
expire
without paying for them the president
would pay for them there's no bill that
exists on this front and we don't even
know what the vehicle would be
but again the president has been clear
about his intention to pay for these
programs and so that's one of the
reasons why this is so disingenuous
but
you're saying that americans aren't
focused on big future data lines for
yesterday brian talked to us for 40
minutes about lots of data points that
are moving in the right direction yeah
i'm wondering given all of those things
and given what you're talking about
prices month to month moving in the
right direction what's the white house's
big picture view on why so many
americans are so pessimistic about the
economy and about the direction of the
country because another data point is
more and more americans are saying right
wrong track on monthly calling on that
key question
well what i was there may be there are
certainly americans who look at data i'm
not suggesting that many of them work in
new york and other places i'm conveying
that the way people experience it i
think you know what i'm saying but the
way people experience it the president
just said this as well is not by looking
at charts in the paper right as much as
we love charts because they're in it's
important for us to note it's about
their monthly budget and how much it
takes to fill up their their tank of gas
uh how much it takes to buy meat to have
burgers for a barbecue that's that's
what i was saying um why are people
experiencing things or why because and i
we've talked about this a little bit
before but
you know a lot of it what we're seeing
in our data is is people's psychology on
the economy on how they're experiencing
things in the country right now is
related to covet and the fact that kovid
we're still in a fight against this
virus
people expected it to be over sooner
we have new variants that have come up
and people are looking to get back to a
normal version of life uh and so that's
our best assessment obviously americans
will experience things different ways
and we certainly understand that but
broadly when you look at data that's
what we see
good thank you jen
um i wanted to ask you something in
light of this week's democracy summit
sure um
former president trump has been
undermining the
2020 election result for most of this
year
um
you know he puts out statements various
releases and i wonder why
president biden has not used his bully
pulpit to push back on the
misinformation coming from former
president trump just given that
democracy is such a top construction why
does president by so i'm just to
understand your question why does
president biden not debate or lift up
president trump and his statements no i
don't think that's what i'm saying why
isn't president biden pushing back on
the misinformation that the former
president is putting out
look i think the president is doing what
the american people elected him to do
which is to govern the country to make
people's lives better to solve kovid to
put people back to work uh and certainly
to fight for protections that will
protect save our democracy and uh moving
forward uh not to continue the 2020
election uh so that's what he's focused
on but do you think it would be
effective in some way to
you know this is the most powerful
possible you know podium that exists in
the united states from a political
leader before has there been any
discussion of the president's giving
some kind of address to the country and
speaking clearly about what did and did
not happen and clearing up this
information and particularly as
democracy is very proud i think the
president has spoken very clearly and
facts back this up about the fact that
the majority of the american people
voted for joe biden to govern this
country uh that it went through dozens
of courts
who threw out attempts to change the
outcome of the election but we've made
an assessment which hasn't been the
assessment made by everybody that
elevating and giving more fire to the
conspiracy theory laden arguments of the
former president isn't constructive nor
is it what the american people elected
him to do go ahead thank you jen um uh
first president in calais of el salvador
posted some apparent screenshots
alleging that uh gene maynes of southcom
uh intervened to try and free another
politician in el salvador
and he alleges that uh she was
intervening to try and free another
politician who was allegedly assisting
gangs in the area of el salvador
is the president aware of this
interaction between maine's and
president bukele and also posting
whatsapp screenshots of a us diplomat
what does this say about the us's
relationship with what was once uh an
intended partner to curb irregular
migration north sure zolan it's a great
question i i don't have all the details
on the specific case um not case but the
specific details of this uh this
incident that you're referring to um so
i can't speak to whether the president's
aware of it obviously he's regularly
briefed by his national security team
but i'll talk to them and see if there's
more details on it okay great and then
uh on mpp uh the homeland security
secretary was asked about the expansion
of mvp
of including haitians i know you were
asked about this earlier this week but
um
when asked about the expanding it he
said we felt the good faith
implementation of this program required
us to act why why is it that expanding a
policy to include more migrants um a
policy that the president has referred
to as inhumane um is acting in good
faith
well i think as the the secretary has
also stated and i've stated too we don't
agree with this program uh we find it um
has endemic flaws it's imposed on
justifiable human unjustifiable human
costs pulled resources and personnel
away from other priority efforts and
failed to address the root causes of a
regular migration i'd also note that
they made some changes to the program to
in attempt to instill some more humane
components even of a program that we are
opposed to uh in terms of uh how we're
implementing it uh i mean my
understanding but i really appointed the
department of homeland security is that
we are abiding by this court order and
working to implement that as we see the
requirement uh but beyond that i would
really point to them for more details
the court order didn't specify expanding
it to other nationalities including
haitians so i mean with everything you
just said given that the administration
has in court documents criticize this
policy i mean why then expand it for
this other population that the trump
administration did not
include even well i would say first of
all the trump administration allowed
this program to continue separated
families and mothers from their children
and had it absolutely inhumane and
horrific approach to immigration so i
don't think there's any point of
comparison there i will check and see if
there's more details on this to share
with you the last one i have is just uh
with this uh
this tragedy involving a truck crash
with more than 50 migrants that were
killed that's the initial reports um
just initial reports from people on the
ground
say that that truck was intending to
come to the u.s border that those folks
were trying to come to the u.s is the
president is the administration um
reaching out to mexico to partners in
central america this morning does this
cause for a certain reevaluation of the
strategy to deter migration norm it
would really come through the department
of homeland security of that kind of
outreach so i would point you to them
for any more detail about a connection
with the mexican government vice
president at this point
i can check and see but i suspect that
conversation would first happen through
the department of homeland security
go ahead
oh go ahead karen um thanks jen um
retail sales recently have been strong
even with prices increasing does the
white house think that will continue or
is there concern about consumers
starting to scale back uh due to higher
prices
we have seen uh retail sales up i mean
it is the holiday season right now so
without being an economist i i suspect
that retail sales are often up around
the holiday season as people are
engaging in retail therapy or what what
have you uh this time of year um in
terms of whether it will come down and
be i think i would assume you mean below
what the typical trend would be uh we we
haven't seen that to date but i don't
have any economic projections of what we
expect on that front or i have not heard
an expectation from economic team that
we expect them to come down
and on a different topic manuel oliver
lost his son in the parkland florida
high school shooting in 2018 he's been
here in washington this week he spoke to
us abc and said he wants to meet with
the president to talk about gun control
in the wake of another school shooting i
know that he's met with the president in
the past and some white house officials
in the past have spoken with him but is
there a plan for the president to meet
with mr oliver while he's here in
washington and then i just have one
quick one after that sure sure well let
me first say that we have been in touch
with mr oliver cedric richmond has been
in touch with him and he's also offered
a meeting with cedric richmond and
members of our senior team
i don't have anything to preview in
terms of a meeting with the president
but
certainly he is somebody as you noted
that who the president has met with in
the past we certainly respect an honor
uh one his loss but also his activism as
a follow-up to that on behalf of gun
safety but i don't have anything to
predict at this point for a meeting with
the president i think you were asked
this earlier this week but just to
circle back on that has the president
spoken with any of the families who lost
a child in the michigan school shooting
last week i don't have an update on that
either at this point in time go ahead so
the los angeles school district has 85
percent of its uh eligible student
vaccinated 12 12 years and older and up
uh but they're pushing back the deadline
for the rest of those students uh
because you know tens of thousands were
not gonna meet that deadline uh how does
the white house view that experience as
a view that this has been a successful
use of a mandate on students does it say
a warning sign that not enough suits are
getting vaccinated how would you
characterize and look at that situation
you know i don't have any specific
specific excuse me great of these of
their their implementation obviously
school districts across the country are
going to implement or not different
requirements to keep their schools safe
uh what i would note um is that that is
a vast majority that is a a compliance
with what the requirements are they put
in place by a large population of the of
the school community um and that is
something they have made the decision
will make their community and their
school safer uh make parents feel more
comfortable and confident in sending
their kids to school that's ultimately a
good thing but different schools are
going to implement it differently i
think the president's principle is
ultimately that there should not be a
cliff uh that there should be efforts to
find accommodation to ensure there's
counseling that there's communication
and education about the efficacy of
vaccines or alternatives like testing
and that is certainly something that uh
we've conveyed to entities across the
country one more question on schools uh
obviously the white house wants schools
to be open but encouraging schools but
yeah many schools are fully open but
inside schools they're often you know
very strict rules uh for example
sometimes students are required to eat
outside or eat fish or not talk to each
other while they're eating does the
white house want to see those rules
lifted as well to get back to a more
normal school experience well schools
are taking steps especially since we've
only recently approved uh through the
cdc and fda vaccines for five to 11 year
olds they're not approved for kids
younger than that to keep their kids
safe and keep students safe i will tell
you i have a three-year-old who goes to
school sits outside for snacks and lunch
wears a mask inside and it's no big deal
to him i'm not saying that's the case
for everybody but these are steps that
schools are taking to keep kids safe and
i think the vast majority of parents
appreciate that obviously we want to get
to a point where we're turning to a
version of normalcy for everybody right
uh where you're not sending your kids
backpack with seven extra masks right
where you're not adding two hats so that
they're warm outside for a snack there's
no question that's the case but we also
think the most important thing should be
safety the safety of kids keeping kids
in school which the president is very
focused on and some of these steps
creative steps that schools have taken
have enabled that to be possible go
ahead tina is the biden administration
considering extending that student loan
payment pause i know um there's
if not besides legislation that probably
won't pass what are some of the options
that can help these people
um you're talking about the student loan
payment pass that expires in february
just for for clarity so um in the coming
weeks we will release more details about
our plans and we'll engage directly with
federal student loan borrowers to ensure
they have the resources they need and
are in the appropriate repayment plan
we're still assessing the impact of the
omicron variant but a smooth uh
transition back into repayment is a high
priority for the administration the
department of education is already
communicating with borrowers to help
them to prepare for return to repayment
on february 1st and has secured contract
extensions with loan servicers so we are
preparing for a range of steps here um
these steps have provided i would just
note more than 12.5 billion dollars in
discharges to nearly 640 000 borrowers
plus tens of billions more saved by the
41 million borrowers who have benefited
from the extended student loan payment
pause but it expires february 1st so
right now we're just making a range of
preparations and then on the olympics um
china earlier this week
said when they learned of the diplomatic
boycott that there might be some
retaliation are there any counteractions
that have been discussed within the
administration
we would certainly let china speak for
themselves as we noted when we made this
announcement
we felt the president felt uh that we
could not proceed with business as usual
and send a diplomatic delegation to the
olympics but obviously
we work with china on issues where there
is agreement and we make clear where we
have concerns and that includes our
strong concerns about human rights
abuses specifically in xinjiang go ahead
thanks john just following up on steve's
question on austin thais yeah you
mentioned that every uh the
administration is doing everything it
can to free him
uh does everything include direct
engagement with the assad government in
syria i'm not going to detail any
anything further our objective is of
course bringing people home and um
not just the tice family but other
families of those who have been held
captive uh have criticized the president
that they haven't seen direct personal
engagement on
their family cases um
maybe you can explain what uh the
president has done uh directly uh to
help free some of these amendments
abroad i'm not going to detail the
president's engagement uh because it's
not advantageous to our objective of
bringing people home what i can tell you
is that uh austin ty's his mother and an
and all of the families of americans who
are being held overseas have been in
touch with our national security team
have been in touch with jake sullivan
and other senior officials in a range of
departments at the state department
others multiple times and we are
absolutely committed to closely
coordinating with them to doing
everything we can
from here in the united states
government to bring their loved ones
home
uh go ahead
following on that uk court ruling on
assange
has the president ever given any
consideration at all to a pardon
and also what is your response to
um the message in some quarters that
prosecuting sound is is a is an assault
on freedom of speech freedom of press
information etc well i i would again
reiterate that this is a case that is
still ongoing it's really under the
purview of the department of justice
they've put out a statement i'd point
you to that for any further comment i
would say broadly speaking outside of
this case that the president has been an
advocate for freedom of speech freedom
of press he's holding a two-day
democracy summit that's wrapping up
today the freedom of media and press is
a central component of that he announced
an additional tranche of funding to
ensure we're advocating for that and he
is somebody who's going to continue to
advocate that domestically and
internationally through the course of
his presidency go ahead nadia thank you
jen um you said you're expecting the
price of oil to go down soon what you
base that on and will the president
reach out to the opec plus uh producer
countries again
well we've already seen the price go
down some so i was basing it on what
we've seen in the data in the oil
markets
and uh yesterday you talked elaborately
about a possible sanctions the economy
extension
iraq
on iran um and you said that you would
send delegations perhaps to the uae and
you know to your allies like japan or
south korea and the rest um two
questions number one is um are you going
back to the maximum pressure campaign
that the previous administration used to
convince iran to come back to the
negotiation and second what kind of
leverage do you have on
china
uh to stop importing iranian oil
well i i would say first we're not using
the last administration approach as a
model um they pulled out of the iran
nuclear deal
which meant that we they've been able to
proceed and progress in their nuclear
program without visibility from the
united states or the global community in
a way that um it leads to a reduction in
everyone's security um and is uh
ultimately uh has enormously negative
impacts uh globally as it relates to
what are leverages on china
china was a constructive member of the
p5 plus one has continued to be
and obviously there are certain
restrictions and requirements everybody
would have to implement
in order for this to move forward that's
all part of the negotiations i don't
think anyone wants to see iran acquire a
nuclear weapon i'm not sure if you would
call that leverage as much as something
that is important to the security of the
global community
thanks um on china u.s trade
representative catherine thai has
previously said there's this range of
enforcement mechanisms on the table to
hold china accountable to the phase one
trade deal but china's on track to fall
short of the goals primarily boosting
imports of u.s agricultural goods how
confident is the president who can hold
china accountable to those commitments
in time since those obligations are
expiring well i know they're expiring at
the end of the year right am i
remembering this correctly uh so we have
a couple more weeks um ambassador thai
is of course a running point for the
administration on the implementation on
these phase one negotiations and
discussions uh i don't have an update
from here uh but i can certainly check
and see if there's more to report
what message does it send to american
farmers who were you know hoping for a
boost from these export obligations if
they aren't men and should we expect the
president to take action if that is the
case well as you know there's an ongoing
review and assessment maybe this is what
i short-handed was referencing that is
over being overseen by ambassador tai
about these tariffs and how they impact
negatively unintentionally certain
industries in the united states i don't
have anything to preview on that front
but that is also an ongoing process
that's happening right now um go ahead
thanks um i follow up on that question
about el salvador what's the white house
response to the president of el salvador
accusations account against the u.s he
says and i quote the interest within the
interest of the united states has
nothing to do with democracy in any
country and vote and um any comment on
the decision of nicaragua to break
relations with taiwan and it to china
sure let me start with nicaragua the
decision deprives nicaragua's people of
a reliable and democratic partner in
taiwan taiwan is a like-minded
democratic partner a steadfast partner
and friend to countries throughout the
region we encourage all countries that
care about democratic institutions
transparency the rule of law and
promoting economic prosperity for their
citizens to expand engagement with
taiwan we refer to the state department
for anything further but i would note
that they put out an extensive statement
on that go ahead
before the president of salvador saying
that
the us government has nothing to do with
democracy in any country
it's hard for me to even know the
context of that statement the united
states just hosted a two-day democracy
summit where we announced uh an
extensive financial commitment uh to uh
contribute to the the preservation of
democracy around the world the president
as the president conveyed democracy
works best with consensus and
cooperation and he's also noted that we
all need to continue to work harder to
preserve our own democracy i don't have
a exact reaction to them go ahead
foreign policy questions one is on
afghanistan yesterday uh as was
mentioned earlier the head of central
command
in an interview and during that
interview he said that the number of al
qaeda members
in afghanistan has in his words probably
slightly increased
does that surprise
the president is that a concern for the
president
well i would say first that um president
biden made clear from the start of the
afghanistan withdrawal process that it's
critical for us to retain our over the
horizon with uh
counterterrorism abilities our abilities
to prevent detect and disrupt terrorism
threats without having a permanent
military presence on the ground
that could be a target
and that is something he is committed to
ensuring our national security team is
working to ensure we have the
capabilities working with partner
countries in the region who share that
concern who do not want uh terrorism to
have a birthplace or rebirth place in
the region and we've also been clear
that we will not allow terrorists to
threaten the homeland from afghanistan
and we will hold the taliban accountable
i know we obviously do regular
assessments for our intel from our
intelligence team on this uh from the
cia director uh from uh our director of
the national intelligence agency i'd
really point you to them on our on their
assessments but the president takes uh
his commitment to ensuring they do not
rebuild they do not gather and they do
not threat pose a threat to the homeland
quite seriously on russia just a few
days after president biden's
conversation with president putin
is it fair to say
that the ball is now in president
putin's court in the sense that
the next step is up to him as to whether
or not he pulls back its troops from the
russian ukrainian border or
he moves into ukraine what what's your
assessment there is that a fair accurate
assessment
well i would say first that our
objective continues to be diplomatic
discussions and and to go back to jeff's
earlier question those could take a
range of formats there's decades of uh
precedent on this and a lot of formats
that exist uh where those could continue
uh and those could uh and that is that
is really our objective and our focus
those would not of course uh involve
just the russians our overarching um
approach here is uh that we're not gonna
have conversations uh without the key
players involved whether that is
conversations about ukraine without
ukraine or conversations about nato
without nato those are our principles so
that's really what our focus is on at
this point obviously all of this uh
effort a diplomatic effort to date
coordination with our european partners
the president's very direct conversation
with president putin was meant to convey
very clearly that if he were to choose
to invade there would be severe and
significant economic consequences
obviously
you know he is the one who has control
over the military troops of russia not
other countries but certainly our effort
and our focus is to have those
diplomatic discussions uh and and and
have the ball move forward through that
channel i think i'm gonna have to wrap
it up here in just a moment let's go
ahead
i have two quick follow-ups um the first
is you've been consistent on this and so
is the president about your support for
codifying roe v wade yeah what's more uh
speaker pelosi and majority leader
schumer have also
voiced their their support has the white
house been doing outreach on this and do
you think that you would have the votes
to be successful
i can't give an assessment of the vote
count at this point what i will tell you
is that we have been engaged uh with
leaders on capitol hill many of whom
have been quite outspoken uh about uh
their concern and the need to move
forward with the women's health
protection act today in light of the
fact that women in texas have been for
101 days they've had their basic access
to women's health care to their
fundamental right that's been the law of
the land for decades uh be put into
question and at risk uh in terms of uh
what our engagement will be we will
continue to be engaged and the the
ruling this morning reinforces that
there is more work to be done reinforces
that need to engage
on capitol hill and with uh localities
around the country
um moments ago you were pretty
definitive when you said that president
biden would only support extending these
programs if they were paid for period
does that necessarily mean that sometime
in the future president biden would be
prepared to raise taxes
well i think president biden's been
pretty clear about his
protection of keeping taxes low for the
middle class and lowering them but we
don't have any hypothetical bill we're
talking about here i think you've seen
him uh convey that pretty clearly and
all of the bills he's supported have
been consistent uh but we'll have
hypothetical we'll have real
conversations when real bills exist
edward why don't you do the last one
thank you thank you jeff so you talked
about inflation here in the room um the
highest we haven't seen since 1982 um
president's been in office about 11
months what grade does the president
give himself on his handling of the
economy
i think every president i've ever worked
for i've only worked for two but they
try not to grade themselves um but i
will tell you what what the president is
proud of working on with congress with
governors with leaders across the
country is his effort to lower prices
for people across the country whether
it's the steps he took to lower the
price of gas whether it's the steps he
took from the beginning to address
bottlenecks in the supply chain that
we're seeing play out now positively in
terms of improvements or whether it's
his effort his proposal to introduce
buildback better which will cut costs
for people across the country all right
happy friday everyone
thank you everyone have a good day
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
you